how can we check if all the images on a
site have been optimized
remember that in order to serve the
smallest possible image file on your
site you need to make sure you've run
images through optimization tools
now one great tool for checking this is
page speed insights let's use that to
check a page from our website one image
that needs some help we can also use
page speed insights from the dev tools
just click analyze
best of all there's a page pagespeed
insights api that lets you incorporate
checking within your workflow here i'm
running a curl command to make an http
request from a terminal
dollar key here holds the value of my
api key for page speed insights and i'm
redirecting the response of that request
to
psi.json
let's open up that file and take a look
at the output
looks like psi found one image that
needs to be optimized same as it did
from the website
you could easily incorporate this into
build tests when pushing code to a
repository for example
using a task runner such as grunt in
fact there's even a grunt plugin for
pagespeed insights for more information
about using pagespeed to check images
with grunt take a look at the link below
the video